rewrite the following expression as the
product of positive exponents and then
evaluate the expression when x is equal
to two so let's do this first part they
want us to rewrite it as the product of
positive exponents so they don't like it
the fact that we have this negative
third power and the 5 to the negative
second power so we want to rewrite those
as negative exponents and to do that we
just have to remember
that something to a negative power is
just let me write it over here if i have
if i have x if i have x to the negative
2 power this is the exact same thing as
1 over x to the positive 2 power if i
have a
to the negative b power this is the
exact same thing as 1 over
a to the b power you can get rid of that
negative by just putting a 1 over this
whole thing by taking the inverse of the
whole expression then you can get rid of
that negative so let's do that over here
x to the negative 3 power that is equal
to this let me just in different colors
x to the negative 3rd power that's the
exact same thing as 1 over
x to the third power by definition and
we're going to multiply that
by 5 to the negative 2 power well 5 to
the negative 2 power same exact thing
that's the same
that's the same thing as 1 over 5 to the
second power 1 over 5 to the positive 2
power
and then finally we have just a straight
up x squared the exponent is already
positive there so we can just leave that
as times
x squared so we did the first part we
rewrote the following expression as a
product of positive exponents
now let's evaluate the expression when x
is equal to 2. so everywhere we see an x
we should put a 2. so this becomes
1 over
2 to the let me do the same colors
this becomes 1 over
two to the third power
times
times one over five squared
two squared every place we saw in x
we're now putting a two
2 to the third power just as a reminder
that's 2 times 2 times 2. that is equal
to
8. so this is equal to 1 over 8 times
5 1 over 5 squared 5 squared
is equal to 5 times 5 which is equal to
so this is equal to 25 and then we're
going to multiply that times 2 squared
so that's times 2 squared is this 2
times 2. let me write this 2 squared is
equal to 2 times 2
which is equal to 4. so times 4. and you
can even view this as times 4 over 1.
and so you multiply all the numerators
that's what we do when we multiply
fractions you multiply all the
numerators 1 times 1 times 4
is equal to 4 and you multiply the
denominators 8 times
25 is going to be 200
is going to be 200 and then you can
simplify this the numerator and the
denominator are both divisible by four
divide the numerator by four you get one
divide the denominator by four you get
50 so this is equal to one
over 50. and just so you see there's
actually a way to simplify it before we
even got to this stage over here it's
actually from this stage we could have
multiplied it out if you let me just
rewrite this thing
so this product if we multiply it out
this 2 squared you can view it as 2
squared
over 1. so if we were to multiply this
out
the numerator
would have been equal to 1 times 1 times
2 squared 2 squared is just 2 times 2
should have been 2 times 2 in the
numerator we can ignore the ones that
doesn't change the value and then the
denominator would have been
2 times 2 times 2 that's what 2 to the
3rd power is 2 times 2 times 2
times 5 times 5
times 5 times 5 that's what 5 squared is
and of course multiplying it by 1
doesn't change this value and then it
would have been more obvious that you
have you can divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2 once you could do
it again
and then you'd just be left with 1 over
2 two times five times five
two times five times five and this of
course down here is fifty this is ten
times five which is fifteen you've
gotten the same result